(lively music)
- [Mosche] Hey, this
is Mosche Kasher.
- [Natasha] And Natasha Leggero.
- And we just got
married six months ago.
- Which we think
pretty much makes us
qualified to give love
advice to strangers.
- So that's what we did.
We packed up the car, hit the
road, and spread the love.
- [Both] This is
The Honeymoon Tour.
- If we were to
really dance like
for real no one's watching,
this is what I think
it would look like.
("Shake" by R'n'G)
(applause)
- I'm so glad you all
were watching that.
(applause)
- What up, bitches?
Y'all ready to party or what?
Ha-ha, yeah.
(laughter)
Just kidding.
It's going to be a lot
less like that from me,
and a lot more like
private liberal art school
up here for a few minutes, so...
(laughter and applause)
- Our only one thing comes
from my, I have a trigger
because I was cheated
on by someone.
- Oh yeah.
That's her thing, is I was
going to say infidelity?
- Yeah, and I can't...
(Natasha laughs)
It's frustrating
that I can't sleep
with other people when
it like seems okay.
- The person I was
with would have
coffees and lunches
with a lot of girls,
and a lot of them he had
had past relationships with,
and I was like
being cool about it,
and then it ended up being bad.
- So you don't love when
he has coffee with girls?
- Yeah, but I'm not
telling him not to have it.
I'm telling him
so he has coffees
and lunches with guy friends.
He'll say the guy's name.
- Uh-huh.
- And when it's been a girl,
he'll be like, a friend.
And I'm like, well who's...
So I have asked of him just
to tell me when it's a girl,
and I recently was like,
have you ever slept with her
or had a relationship with her,
and he got really mad
at me for asking that.
I started off our
conversation by saying
this has nothing to do with you.
I have a trigger that
I'm trying to get past,
and it will go away in
time, and it would just
help me if there wasn't
just a vagueness.
And then later--
- It's not going to help you.
- It wouldn't help you.
- But I would just
like not a friend.
Be like I'm with my
friend, Courtney.
- But then you're the one--
- And it's like we
69ed once in 2012.
- No, that part--
(Natasha laughs)
- I had a boyfriend once,
and I thought maybe
something was going on.
But then I started like
going through his stuff,
and I remember I read
like bad diary entries.
And it made me so upset,
and it was all kind
of his fantasy,
and it kind of
ruined everything.
And I always told myself I'll
never look at anyone's email.
I just got over it.
- What do you got, Ed?
- She likes to drink
bottled water constantly.
And instead of sipping
it like a normal person,
she'll suck it out of there,
so she'll crush the bottles.
(laughter and applause)
- That is so specific.
- Like I don't know,
just like gross
because like every time she goes
for a water bottle,
it's just like
(yelling)
- Okay and Sam,
what do you have to
say about this, in your defense?
- It doesn't sound like
that much of a problem.
- That's true, except if you
cut the little stuff out,
then you never build
up to big stuff.
Like you guys will get married,
you'll have spent
40 years together,
and then one day you'll
be like an old woman,
and you'll be in a rocking
chair, and you'll be like
(gurgling)
And he'll just come in
with a side of frozen lamb.
(screams)
(laughter)
I told you 40 years
ago to stop this!
- I actually feel
better after you guys,
because I'm like oh okay, cool.
It's like oh, so I can
just like let this go.
- The thing about trust
is that it's either
the person's either worthy of
your trust, or they're not.
The circumstances
around it don't matter.
It's like you either
got a scum dude,
or you got a not-scum dude.
- And sometimes
they're not even scum,
they're just too young
or something, you know?
- [Andree] Yeah.
- It's like they're
just in experienced.
- And also they say
that something like
70% of married couples
have a cheating partner.
- [Andree] Oh my God.
- [Moshe] So it's kind of like--
- [Natasha] You think?
- [Moshe] It is a betrayal.
- That's crazy.
- [Moshe] It is a betrayal,
but it's such a common betrayal,
it's like is it even
that big of a betrayal?
- [Andree] It's such
a French betrayal.
(Natasha laughs)
- It's a classic
French betrayal.
- Is there anything that
Ed could do differently?
- Besides the shirt, I guess?
(laughter)
- He's very passive-aggressive
about his roommates.
Like his roommate broke a dish,
so he wrote him a note.
Tell him, like be like
dude, you broke my dish.
(laughter)
Or like where's my rent check?
- Okay, I have an idea.
- [Moshe] Okay Natasha.
- How about you guys
move in with each other--
- [Moshe] I like it.
- And you stop doing that
weird thing with your water.
(laughter and applause)
- That seems very good.
That seems great.
Ed and Sam, we've
made love happen.
- Just stop doing it!
- Thank you.
(slow jazz music)